[Music]
uh rude customer harasses appliance
delivery driver oh boy here we go
and i paid for you guys to take the old
one but you're being hostile you're
cussing you want to start dropping n
words and stuff get away from me i
didn't call you
jesus christ
[Laughter]
sir
you just did
no but like no but like i didn't
actually like like i said no like okay
man dude like okay
but like i yeah i said i said it but
okay like you see
what happens i haven't had my i haven't
had my coffee yet
i started dropping inwards and stuff get
away from me i didn't call you
[Music]
say the actual words go help huh okay
guys to take the old one but you're
being hostile you're cussing you want to
start dropping inwards and stuff get
away from me i didn't call you
[Music]
larry you can't even say with an a larry
what i tell you don't even say with an a
at the end
[Laughter]
[Music]
i said i never just did i said i never
said you were
[ __ ] away from me before i sleep your
ass one morning we're summoned ap just
let you know yeah i know
do it right now come on come on you got
the ball for me
you don't want to jump
it's all right you pay for it you'll get
what you paid for so you're just going
to step away from me sorry man come on
now there ain't no apologies this time
man i got a cus i got them on the line
they just heard everything that went
down so i suggest you back away and
they're also
wait for me man i'm gonna pay for you
guys you take the old one you paid for
back away from me
okay in california
hey keep the camera on because you
already lost
you already dropped the n word on camera
who gives a sh i'm sorry but i look
i get but can we stop pretending like
that means you're gonna you have to face
a military tribunal
like let's [ __ ] calm down all right
he clearly said he didn't call you it
no i said i don't say that
get away from me put the [ __ ] on the
truck bro no all right
can you get the uh can you get the
always sunny and philadelphia title
music cued up sure hold on and then uh
and then i just i just dm'd you on on
not it's not in the locker i just sent
it to you
and then you can
play that pull me that clip back again
all right uh let's see here
okay okay okay
okay it's gonna be hard because i i
might have to do a lot of scene changes
but i could do it okay give me a second
i have to actually set this up it's not
gonna i'm telling you right now i'm
gonna be easy but i'll do my best okay
all right here we go
oh boy it's too many scene changes all
right all right hold on let me let me
make i got to make sure the music is
cute okay the music is cute all right
here we go
it's not going to be perfect so i'm
apologizing right now okay
um
okay here we go
and i paid for you guys to take the old
one but you're being hostile you're
cussing you want to start dropping
inwards and stuff get away from me i
didn't call you a [ __ ]
i said i never did
[Music]
do it right now come on come on you got
the wallet
[Music]
i know it makes it better right
[Music]
[ __ ] man
we did that live do you understand that
we did that live without any
pre-planning